[Music]
when people are drunk they are more
honest than ever I also have fries
between my legs my pants are still wet
from the other news no one is a see Zach
there are people who want to see that we
as the try guys will empirically decide
the best fast-food restaurant in the
universe are we done with this like an
intro thing I just want to eat the
burgers this is a battle number one
McDonald's versus Burger King the
ultimate burger showdown to eat without
me mother fires it's a piece of stray
lettuce when it comes to junk burgers
I'm a Burger King man I normally don't
support a monarchy but I do in this case
do you think Ronald McDonald paints his
whole body oh no it's just the face you
don't know that this I do you don't know
that yeah Ronald's my neighbors I'm
starting with the whopper look how
immaculate that top is like it was just
kissed by the heavens like they painted
these seeds on individually it's so
beautiful John talking too much
boo it's grilled grain boiled flame
bread rainbows next we move on to the
McDonald's Big Mac why is this has bread
in the middle that's ludicrous wow it's
like the burger that says do you eat
bread I didn't want max are so
particular until I've been drunk I will
say aesthetically this is cuter but but
burger K's a Burger King not a fry Lord
final verdict the fries at McDonald's
are better but the burger hamburger and
the waffle place you're killing it I
love this I would rather have McDonald's
better sauce better burger people papa
time mix chicken game we got Louisiana
verse Kentuck I egg everyone loves fried
chicken everyone I'm sorry no one as
much as Keith it's so good one just the
[Music]
so good oh my oh my ja it's I'm into it
that's breeze it's like a little ninja
with all their weight their names
combined so then you're on purpose this
is so good that it's making me forget
what KFC even tastes like let's taste
Kentucky oh [ __ ] this is good the
seasoning come on Casey is making drunk
key thing peppery just put glue me and
bathtub full of biscuits let's just
taste us about this is the best arroz de
pekka later everybody's a winner well
[ __ ] me and call me and uncle's donkey
yeah I think it's KFC KFC can't believe
I might say that Wow I'm kind of like
wow better quality chicken better
seasoning no easy in a fast
which will you remember and now the
final rounds of the fast food drunk
gauntlet
the battle between tacos and pizza both
of them come in a box Taco Bell oh my
car so good no I couldn't eat a whole
pizza drunk by myself
I have even hoping just drop by myself I
have never had this cool rain taco do we
have any sauce this fight is over we
can't leave Pizza Hut without sauce okay
let's eat it what is this it's not a
taco - taco what the hell is this I
don't see the Doritos in here oh this is
supposed to be a nursery you know this
is a Dorito oh it is what Frankenstein
[ __ ] is this isn't it weird it's amazing
is an amazing
fast food product like blowing my mind I
hate Taco Bell and yet everything about
this taco it's amazing they've got
stores nationwide for a reason oh I
appreciate talk about cuz they didn't
shy away from their stoner roots well so
like seven-year-olds though which one
would you prefer between these two
what's a pizza
let's eat their goods because of my
allergies I know this is gonna give me
diarrhea this is a dice roll out of
everything we've tried today what is the
best KFC there I said it
more than okay yes I did Cassie was
incredible it blew my braids apart my
dick is gone where dirt is going I
really like pizzahut
I'm sticking with the King Burger King I
would eat the most
I will not either thrower when you get
drunk you should get drop of friends if
you have enough friends
you can order all of this why choose one
you could have it all here's a real
question that do you think it would
taste good if we combine them hmm no
that's terrible
that's a bad decision I was a bad cup is
not good that was wrong or even a drunk
person knows that's bad yuk yuk yuk this
is not Papa John's